Pulling on your swim trunks, hopping in the
car and going to the beach is a scene you
probably don't associate with winter, unless,
you like a good
Polar Bear Swim.
The polar bear plunge seems like a crazy thing
to do.
Firstly, if you're not familiar, a polar bear
swim is a when a person jumps into a body
of water when it's cold outside.
Over 2000 people do it at Coney Island, outside
of New York City, on January 1st, every year.
These cray people are members of the Polar
Bear Club, and they literally do this for
fun, all the time.
I'm cold inside just THINKING about doing
this, but what it DOES to your body… is
pretty damn cool; no pun intended.
Physiologically, the human body thinks of
anything below 70 degrees as a "cold" temperature;
we evolved in Africa, cold isn't really part
of our inherent biological programming.
So, when you jump into 40 degree (4.5 C) water,
your body goes into cold shock response.
The body will constrict blood vessels at the
surface of the skin, increase respiration
-- usually you'll see people gasping for air
-- and a surge in heart rate.
There's no real danger, unless the swimmer
has a heart condition.
Hypothermia isn't likely either; the core
body temperature can maintain for a long while;
though arms and legs will become very cold.
You'd have to stay in the water for 30 minutes
before you'd need to worry.
Winter swimming isn't just a novelty practice
to shock the system.
There are actual scientific benefits.
In Northern Europe, plunging into icy cold
water is considered a stress reliever, usually
after a period in a sauna.
A study in the International Journal of Circumpolar
Health found an improvement of general well-being
versus a control group.
They followed two groups of people over a
winter season, after four months, the people
who participated in winter swimming "felt
themselves to be more energetic, active and
brisk" but also reported a relief of pains
from rheumatism, fibromyalgia, and asthma!
Reports from people who participate in the
annual Coney Island dip report feeling invigorated
and relaxed after the experience -- this is
due to the adrenaline and stress hormone release
in response to the cold shock.
It's essentially triggering your fight-or-flight
response, but not following up with any danger
-- this results in temporary euphoria!
Another peer-reviewed study in QJM found people
who participate in regular winter swimming
experienced oxidative stress, which caused
their bodies to increase their natural antioxidant
levels!
Even further studies found winter swimmers
have stronger circulation and a 40 percent
reduction in infections of the respiratory
system!
Just by taking a dip in cold water.
When I was a kid, I would sit in the sauna
for 10 minutes and then jump in the cold pool…
My mother always said it was good for the
skin, but I couldn't find any solid evidence
of it.
It was a great feeling though!
Chances are it felt great because of a moderate
cold shock response, thanks, Mom!
Would you do a polar bear swim?